Okay, I'll if you could please introduce yourself your name in today's date and
our location. I'm Albert C. Par where we're at our home in
Gresham, working on these two at Avenue and the day to date I believe is the 18th
is 18th of June 2014. Terrific. Well we'll start at the beginning of your
born in, is it to Lee, Utah? To Iowa they call it to Utah. Yeah. So what was your
family doing there? My dad was working in the copper mines and a big army
depot at the two-o-ordinance depot during World War II and after the war ended
decided he wanted to leave Utah and move up to Oregon where his brother was
family was in Rosbury. So we moved to Rosbury I think in 1946 something like that
in 1946 or early 1947 and that's why I went to all my schooling and grew up
there in Rosbury. Did you have siblings? Yes I have one brother and my
older brother and an assistant for this four-year shelter and they all they both
live in the state. My sister lives in Canberra, my brother lives in Lake
Grover Lake, Oswigal. So your dad was in the copper mines originally but I
understand he was in the forest products industry. He worked in the saw mills
and plywood mills in the Rosbury area and eventually ran a film station for a
while and some other things just sort of retired as a handyman and mechanic.
It's a place in Rosbury. Growing up in Rosbury, did you have any, do you have
memories of the temper culture at that time? Yeah there was a lot of, you know
that's what made the the the world hum down there and in those days they were
still giving a lot of those first growth trees and it'd be Douglas Firs and
you take up a whole logging truck the diameter would be and you'd see those
coming down the road and the road is of course really very primitive up in the
mountains there's a lot of them are at least gravel not paid but it was very
primitive but there was a that's what that was almost excuse me. There's also a big
farming industry in Rosbury in the garden valley a vegetable farming can't
load beans that sort of thing. There were a lot of less kids in a junior high
school high school worked in the farms in the in the valleys there and in the
Rosbury area. That's why I started working in the farm areas to
say about my new good working state. So what kinds of jobs did you do? Well I
started in junior high school picking beans the pole beans and then eventually
got a that was by a profound sort of job and then eventually I got a job by the
hour sort of an overseer of that and also the
and then soon summers and running in Camel fields and the guy worked
for about 25 acres of Camel open to make those strawberries that sort of
thing and I would work all from me a spring on through the late summer we fall
after school and on the weekends for the farmers. Was there much smag
and labor in the area at that time? Not much at all very very little
in fact that's why the school based the road the school busses downtown and
all kids after work in the fields and I don't think that's done anymore.
I think the children don't want to work out in the hot sun but that's what it used to
be done back in the 50s and 60s that had never before that. It was
getting it get yourself into the school and the school busses load up and go to
the various bean fields and then you work all day they bring you back to the
school and you could get yourself home somehow. What do you remember about your
dad's work in the song mill? I mean what was it a typical work experience
like for him? It was very hard work and of course the mills were not the
air condition or heated or any of that nature and so it was hard it was hard
dirty work and not the safest thing in those days either but it was very
labor intensive you know all the work was done by hand and of course power
solves that sort of thing but you walk into a modern plywood mill you know
there's very few people and it's all automated but most days everything was
done by hand including making the plywood sheet you know layer by layer
like I had a job one summer after in college working in a plywood mill
it was my job to make the plywood it started out with the big flat piece a
four-bake piece and put the machine just spit out glued cross pieces to
even slap those down some water then flop another the other sheets on and
physically built the piece of plywood with your hands and stacked them up and
put them in a big hot press and press them and started another batch
but it was all hand labor you see including you know they do the glued pieces
and all parts of the process were had so they employed a lot of people
compared to what now they do sounds a little repetitious yeah it's boring but
it was good money you know for a kid in those days how about she might have what was
her background she was a school teacher and so since we moved to to Rosberg she
got a job in looking glass so teaching there in looking glass and would go out
every day during the school year and so we were very young so we were we had
often had babysitters and that sort of thing and then eventually she moved to
the Rosberg school system and retired for 30 years or whatever that was Rosberg
going up for you I loved it it was a you know safe place to be
and had a lot of friends there still do so have my road road contacts and
we we I liked it the weather was nice and it's a lovely place to live and of course
a small town but I hope you're you know very fond memories of it really great
place schools were good and so everything did everything to recommend it in my mind
what were your hobbies as a boy what'd you do for fun?
I was pretty busy working we lived on a small farm so we had a lot of animals that
always had pigs and chickens and now occasionally a cow on a steer and that sort of thing
so busy with that sort of thing and then hobbies as I got over was cars got real
interested in hot rod racing and a bunch of us would you know run these hot rods you'd see back
in the 50s and drag race on the on the roads and that sort of thing but that had a good time but
it was entertaining it was a nice place to grow up how about your experience at school
the Rosberg had good schools in those days and I presumably still do and so it was I learned
a lot I was a for a few years for a few years of my school I didn't take schooling very seriously
and I you know got by but and nothing to nothing to do brag about academic excellence but
by the time I got to high school and later on and I started taking school and we're
seriously worked on getting good grades and that sort of thing but again they they were very
tolerant and I was active in student government in high school and and so on so I had a good time
I enjoyed I looked back with the high school with with Creek Fawn this I saw a lot of friends from
from the Rosberg graduating class and I see them and I was just talking to one on the phone this
morning it'll buddy from Rosberg so the you know you know friendship lasted you know it started
and laughed the last of lifetime you know from from your high school experience I see the
education was an emphasis in your family yeah I heard from the time I was very small that you want
to work hard so you can go to college and my dad would always say so you don't have to work in the
mills like I have to work and I want you to work in the mills you could see what he met and so
what it was a good impetus working in the mills and in hard labor on the farms that there might be
a better career perhaps more in terms of ease but also security because the mills are always
having strikes where there was before the union really got strong and that people get laid off
and it was not the most secure environment so a lot of anxiety but for my father and the other
parents as well because of the changing nature of the scene in terms of the the mills and who
was oh who won't this one they buy some mills and everybody get fired and so on and it was a
I could understand why my father was always apprehensive it was a uncertain time
how did you develop your interest in science I was always fairly good at it always a math and
science things always came easy to me it's just one of my abilities and I did well at it and I
just got I was always interested in how things work I built radios from time I was like a teenager
and you could interest in radios not let it interest you know in physics and electronics and
always had that interest in high school then when I went on to college that was the first thing I
you know thought about it as having a major in terms of physics and math so it's a it's just a I
think things sort of select you by your abilities some people have great musical skills and other
kinds of skills language skills and there's some of us who have math and science skills it just
attributes and interest to and from believer in that there's dispositions and characteristics of
people that a lot of them to succeed because some people no matter how hard they work have a
very difficult time with mathematics I would see that when I was teaching and there wasn't that they
were you know necessarily stupid people learning of that nature just they didn't have those those
particular abilities in perhaps interest with abilities and so people tend to end up I think
and things if they're going to be successful that they have good abilities like that's what worked
out for me and you know was there anybody who during your high school time was a mentor for you
or somebody who got interested in these things or do sort of my marriage from within I had a
series of very good science teachers in high school physics teachers and chemistry teachers and
math teachers I might add that always encouraged and encouraged the students and then kept you on
the straight now in terms of the learning did a good job so I think the I had the benefit of a
bunch of good teachers most of the more veterans from World War II that when the ones I can remember
that had gotten to school in the GI building and went into education they were they were really
excellent teachers a lot of benefit to us of students we went to Oregon State College beginning
in 1960 how did you decide to go to OSC I had a scholarship from the from the maybe and
was in our TC scholarships and that was the place that had that program also I wanted the major
in the science program for Georgia State was a natural choice and they had the in our TC scholarship
as well so it was a confluence of events and interest as well as so this a little scholarship aid was
were you in in our OTC in high school or no no no not at all but there was one of those exams you
take and you selected and so on I know it was a competitive thing so that was part of your
experience then in college was being in in energy in our TC yes yes I was in that for two and a
half years then I decided that it would be better for me to continue in science for the
continues the Naval Officer and disenroll from that program just to sit my time in the science
program what did that program entail for you the in the Navy program that would entail the summer
cruises you would after your freshman year you went on the camp pedal tendent some other places
than after the sophomore year we went to Texas for a while at Air Force that Air Force based on
the Corpus Christi and then another month or so at San Diego and so it's good to realize
experience I really think well those experiences in the Navy in the summer programs and then if I
had stayed in the program the third year after your junior year you'd be going to onboard a ship
as some sort of capacity but I never never went that far I put some type of my junior year
was there training during the school year two years? Oh yes did the regular RCC program I think
it was you had to regular class three times a week then one one day there was a drill
where you had to read out it was a marching outside down there all those fields were
other buildings was down there the quants of that building really? There's still the same building
handle it's like down there by the Colosseum and so forth it was the same building then and those
were World War II quants that hosted so it's amazing it's still standing with all those
fields were all vacant there there's not a letter the development that's we'd be out there marching
endlessly it's same yeah yeah there used to be quite a few of those quants at that time campus
I'm sure you saw yeah yeah well what do you remember about you sort of your first impressions of
of college and of corralis? I liked it I was uh when we got there I was selected to go into some sort of
they were trying to move living living arrangement programs and they were also getting started
what they called an honors program at that time and I was enrolled in that and they put people
in that honors program as your freshman the whole four on the first four cauthern hall I believe
he was cauthern hall all four four were so people that were chosen for this honors program and
and they encourage extra cultural activities and and they had advisors and and so forth and it was
it was a pretty much a pretty nice bunch of of fellows who would you know well fairly successful
in high school and we were then selected for this this honors program arrangement I don't know
if they still do that or not I have my idea but it was a I was a introductory program so the people
that we were my roommates and then the people and the hall were pre selected out by by someone in
the university as a part of this honors program that tests to have the better students in one
location the people they perceive to be better students really ultimately turned out or not I
don't know but that was that was the idea of the time and there was extra curriculum activities as
well yeah and then the honors program you took an addition to your regular courses there was
at least one seminar a week of a you know small small bunch of people even sometimes one on one
with one of the professors working on projects I found that very beneficial I worked with
biology botany and botany professor once in physics professors and entomology so it was
interesting time and did that every year for your whole four years and then you
would when you graduated you get an honors designation on your diploma interesting see you're
helping assist with their research yeah you would do and then do the little projects on your own yeah
and it was it was it was always sort of interesting and then just talk about
you know their field of research and then trying to learn a little bit a little bit about it
but it was a broadening experience yeah but you got to work sort of one on one with with the
faculty members or in some cases my physics program was working with a senior graduate student but
coming once a twice a week and we were working on projects and the physics program yeah that's
I'm interested to hear you talk about this though there was I've known that honors program
apparently it started right around the new started it was cut as a result of out measure five
in the early 90s and then was replaced by the University Honors College which came about five
years later it sounds like it's a little different yeah but your experience was yeah it was uh
you they they in some of the class of the segregated in terms you know the people in the honors program
but by and large you just mess with with everybody else and then and did these extra things
with the seminars you know one or three are seminar credit course and get credit for them as well
it was a main main experience was being able to work with one on one with a with a researcher
or some sort and and explore new areas so it was a very beneficial so when you went to college
you have a sense of what you wanted to do in terms of your studies because as a turn of that you took
it I've looked at your academic records you took a lot of classes and to get two degrees in four
years was that your plan from the beginning I sort of liked it because I was the the math and the
physics were happened to be easy for me and the things that caused me trouble were the foreign
language requirements that you know that was really hard for me it's been probably more time on
French when I was taking it then I then I did on the physics courses because it's just different
abilities but no I just really liked the physics course I took as much as I could now select the
math courses but I'd taken a lot of math in high school I really liked it and they had some good
professors too in both departments it was it was a fun and fun environment so I looked back on
my days both at undergraduate and graduate school with great farmers because I enjoyed it and
it was hard work and so forth was really a nice time you were doing something you really wanted
to do and able to do and sort of free from the necessities that happened to make a living otherwise
and work in a workplace and so on it was the time of your life and a pro long time in my case
that went on to graduate school where you were doing exactly what you wanted to do and that's a
that's a real good feeling it's very very good for the soul did you have a sense of a
particular specialty within math or physics at that point in your life or that you know I did not
know but then in fact the curriculum was sort of everybody took the same thing there were a few
electives like in physics you could take it maybe into meteorology or something of that nature
or ocean sciences was getting started back that some people would maybe take a few of that but
by the large the physics curriculum was pretty well fixed and since I was getting a math major
too I didn't have a lot of a slop I had to take the you know the required courses and and to fill
the the social science requirements as well and I think that PE requirements in those days too
that you had to take some of your classes in yeah I don't know if it was still current when you
were in school you used to have to learn how to swim in order to graduate yeah and that was that
was yeah you had to take a swimming course and those days and I I always thought it was awful
they no swimming suits you swam nude and I thought that was just a trotious I mean there's no
earthly sense in it there's just some very peculiar people running the swim program in the athletic
department I think that was my that was always my opinion they just strange folks you're not the
first person to say that to me well were there any professors that made a particular impact upon
you that you can think of yeah I like the entomology professor I worked with John Latin I believe
was the same was was very influential got me interested in in in philosophy of philosophy of
science a whole range of things other than learning a bit very little about entomology but a little bit
and we had some good professors in the physics department too and enjoyed that a great deal
they were they were good because they were student focused and then he really got a chance to
have a lot of experiences with the teachers yeah Latin also was a book lecture oh I didn't know
that at the time yeah we have a Latin book collection that did you work while you were in school
yeah a sum the in our TC program catch kept you pretty busy but also leader on helped by
greeting papers and and that sort of thing for both the math department and the physics department
and that was a small amount of money but it actually helped but it's primarily in the
ingrowning papers and acting as sort of assistant to some professor and that sort of thing I didn't
you know working a restaurant or any that sort of thing well and when you were studying physics
especially I'm interested in knowing about the technologies that were important to students at
that point well we we had the technology of the 50s in the early 60s right and so there
there were a lot of old Hula Packard and Technonics measuring equipment that sort of thing and
the optic stuff was you know all the classical optics material and a lot of that's probably still
still the same because things like optics haven't the introduction of the laser and some of that
technology haven't changed that much so it lends us and that sort of thing you know probably the same
knowledge as they were then and that they had I think well equipped laboratories and for the time
and it was it was good yeah I'm always interested in knowing about the era before computers
and computers we know anyway yeah well there was none of that then the university had a computer
then and it was I started to take a computer course what I always thought this was sort of fun
showed up in this class and turns out most of the other people already knew what they were doing
and you know and so the professor was talking to them somebody like me it was just out the lunch
eventually I just quit the course because you know they need you to tell you where the computer was
and how you did anything they just started talking about a bunch of stuff that they were you know
more advanced it wasn't an introductory course at all which is what it was alleged to be
and so it was sort of a bad experience quite frankly my introduction to computers and they had
something that we were gonna save that time I have no idea it was I never personally sought because
I got out of the business and then really get started into computers till later in graduate
school in very late in graduate school and then like became a talk for a few years in Alabama
we started automating some some of our equipment then but it was still back in those those
they were like in the 60s it was still calotypes not sort of console it was a modems and very slow
I mean people just wouldn't recognize it now they wouldn't have the patience for it
did you so you lived in a dorm initially did you stay in the dorms all four years or no I didn't I
yeah that I I didn't really like the dorms because they're sort of noisy and I'm the sort of
person who really have to have a sort of quiet and it's a little solitude and the dorms were always
very very noisy so the second year I and a friend found an apartment over by the SAE house it's
the church it's a church said they want to be able to story house they rented out parts of
for students so my friend and I moved in moved in there and at that time that wasn't that wasn't
really allowed I mean you had an undergraduate who were supposed to live in student approved housing
well this wasn't student approved housing we just moved in there but eventually the dean caught
up with us the dean of men yeah send us letters which we ignored and so forth but if it's he came over
and not from the door I don't remember his name but he was a very nice man and we talked him
a while I told him I just you know we liked it there and it was and I was getting good grades and
being successful so it wasn't like we were and same with my roommate we're flunking out of school
something it was actually being quite successful as a living arrangement but so he blesses heart he
went next door or graduate student and his wife were living who I didn't know and got them to
sign that they would be our proctors or whatever they called it signed it that they would keep my
office and so then it became legitimate housing and I hadn't realized that it was a process to
to turn a living situation to university recognized but then that was the end of that never
anymore about it but when I stayed there for the next two years and the third year we up
I finally we lived a roommate and I lived in a place called Krobalas towers or something like
that it was a high-rise building at that time in Portland area I mean then in the Krobalas area
and that that was that was fine too but that first one was a sophomore when we ran into the dean
that's having a little concern but you know I was trying to do what I thought was best for me and
I'll find it but at that point this is still true to some degree but at that point the Greek
system was very big on campus and I'm wondering what it was like to not be part of that to have
tried to have a social life but not necessarily the engage with the Greek system we need to engage
with the Greek system not much I had some friends over in fraternity in fact I met some of the
fellows that lived across the street at the SE house and they were all fine we got long fine
there's no problems and we since I had I was doing a double major in health also working I
didn't have a lot of time for socializing and I'm not in those days I didn't think much of party
and carrying on like I emphasized I liked it quite so I could get my work done so I never really
thought about that the fraternities and they were a little more expensive too I think to live
than because by sharing an apartment the rim was relatively small another kind of shared the rent
and you did a lot of cooking and this food preparation and it was really fairly inexpensive I would
I would budget about a thousand dollars maybe eleven hundred dollars a year to go to work and
stay in those days and with a little judicious spending and care you could make almost that amount
in a summary of the working on the farms or plywood mill or a sawmill or something like that
nature and so you could quite easily work your way through school of course I had a
scholarship to the first two and a half years to pay the tuition and I think they gave us
fifty dollars a month for living to as part of that Navy program so it was you know small
stipend and so the financial aspects of going to college and in the 60s and in sort of the
earlier two were just not burdensome almost anybody with a will could could could go to any school
that they wanted the weather was you know Oregon University of Oregon or Oregon State or Southern
Oregon College in any school because you could work your way fairly straightforward now I think
that's not quite probable likely not possible did you have any major extracurricular activities that
you did during during college not much except the that played you know tennis and things like this
with with friends but I didn't during a lot of clubs or anything of that nature because you
know it's pretty busy and they focus on my my activities but a lot of friends we did think we'd
often you know have your your 49 out of the bar down there the peacock water reason one was bars
down there and and have a good time and that that was it but I didn't join but didn't during a lot
of clubs or anything of that nature to any particular hangout besides the peacock
not really but of course everybody you know would have a few beers on the only
close check if you got away to get it even though it's not not not legal in many respects but
students as always are inner pricing and and was never a problem well I ask you about a few
events that happened at Oregon State when you were there the first one in 1961 Oregon State
College began Oregon State University that made much of an impact on you to be memory of that
I have remember and I and the people there thought it was a big deal I remember everybody being
enthused about it because I guess and a lot of people's minds the the name university has more
prestige and meaning than in college and I guess it does personally at that time I I didn't care
that much as I recall because you know I had known as Oregon State College OSC you know
as a high plus where I applied it didn't mean a lot to me in terms of a blade of things because
whether degree whether your degree said Oregon State College or State University to me it didn't
mean very much but you know to some people and I can understand it it did mean a lot to them
because I think in the in the academic hierarchy being called a university is more meaningful
and you know college it's it's more restricted term doesn't imply the research and graduate
programs and so forth that you you think of in terms of the university and I think that was that was
the goal of course in October of 1962 is the Columbus Day Storm you remember that?
vaguely yeah and you know it's a bad storm and I didn't affect me in any way you know
directly we didn't lose any of our home or any of that nature you didn't grow awesome like the
parents and those were didn't have any problems and so I didn't it didn't drastically
drastically affect me in any way but they didn't get to it I don't get it you're a big flip-off
but Terry Baker won the highest trophy in 1962 as well do you remember the much hoopla or surrounding
that? oh yeah there was a lot of hoopla and he was a great athlete because he was a he started
in the basketball the basketball as well and I didn't know him personally of course but he was
famous in his own time and I used to go to football games and they I think the students got in
you know free or or all those stuff and if there was it was a game you know it's not otherwise
engaged I try to get down to watch right I enjoy football it's the one sport I do care for I
and not really a basketball or baseball fan that much but I do like football and so I go some of the
games but in all the hoopla associated with it so I enjoy the athletic teams well what was your
sense of corral at the time somewhat smaller place than it is now obviously any particular
relationship with the town I like Corbalacy was the the people were friendly and nice and
there there there wasn't a crime to speak of and you know I'd read my bicycle outside in my
in my house or the apartment where I lived I I never had a stolen and this sort of thing and
never had a stolen from in front of a building or anything like that so yeah I enjoy I have no
negative memories of it at all of course they it's a lovely campus I always thought Oregon state
had a truly lovely campus in spring when everything's in bloom and the landscaping is it's really
really nice and in those days they didn't have all those cut streets all the streets went through
and you didn't have all the limited access that you have now and but parking was critical I mean
it was not easy when I lived my part I got an apartment system problem without in the dorm you had
to park way down there by pass the tennis course by the call seam and walk across the fields and
so forth there was no parking close by so it was inconvenient for some of the cars in those days
but yeah it was I like Corbalacy it's a lovely little town and it's sort of a nicer place to live
than why you ended up going to grad school and then South Chicago I mean night and day I was sure
yeah I'm sure of that well that brings us to this sort of the next section of your life you
graduated in 1964 from Oregon state how did you decide what you're going to do next?
well I had decided back in my junior year when I got out of the Navy that out of the NROTC
program that I wanted to go on to get a degree of PhD in physics and do research and work at
research labs but I really liked that and so I applied to graduate schools and I was interested in
after getting away from the West Coast so I applied to the University of Chicago and a couple
of schools out of West here I don't remember I think Berkeley and University of Washington and I got
accepted by the University of Chicago and they offered me a research of fellowship and and
assistantship so that covered the education of course they paid the tuition to so I was able to go
to the University of Chicago you know actually by the time I finished I was saved up a little money
that's where I met my wife too as a Chicago in 1966 so it was it was a it was an applied
by Joe Chicago's mother's it's a good school and the financial aid package was very generous I
thought and it was a different part of the country it was interesting to move out to another part
of the country and what's certainly different I mean it was a it was a real lesson to me never
having been to Chicago I didn't interview the school or anything like that I got accepted and I
I don't know 57 Dodge Station working at the time I loaded up all my stuff and drove across Montana
and on down into into Chicago and right there and I wondered you know what's going to survive because
it's a very different environment yeah tell me about that transition you're living in a major
city living in a I have a rough part of a major city yeah it was yeah the South South Chicago was
in a transition from a widely white Polish Irish community to primarily black or African American
and then there was all those problems associated with that in terms of you know the cultural clashes
and so you you you would see that frequently and a lot of you know racism on on both sides but
particularly as as as the population and pro population profile demographic change in these
neighborhoods there was a lot of trouble and people's minds anyhow and so it was it was an
interesting interesting things of course it's something you'd not exposed to an organ at all you
would never had any idea and so it was a from a town like Corvallis with a very few minorities at
least at that time good Chicago or in South Chicago you know somebody like me a white person was
a minority and it was it was a real experience and it gives you perspective on how minorities in
this country the kinds of perceptions they must have and some of their some of their
perplexions I guess what causes trouble and anxieties but it's a it's a good lesson I think for
everybody yeah well the University of engineering too was a world class university in the University of
Chicago very high-powered in the sciences tell me a little bit about that atmosphere that you
you came into at that point it was it was it was it was very competitive I mean the students for
all you know you know very very bright I remember the chairman told me that everybody in the
in the class had GRE scores in the 98 percentile above and and they were all really really really
successful successful students it was very competitive fortunately I my back on at Oregon
states sort of mean good said I had no problems with the academics and and work at that Chicago and
it was one well and made the normal course of events and graduated in a six seven years with a PhD
was a typical time for physics in those days at Chicago I think it some of the other majors take
it was less time but so I graduated in the early 1970 with a PhD I want to ask you about a
couple people that were there I believe when you were there that are big names the first is an
Indian fellow superb onion chundra shigar absolutely he's a great professor I had him for a
couple of classes actually and statistical physics and and and and atomic and molecular physics quantum
mechanics advanced quantum mechanics and he was a brilliant teacher and he would come in and just
started his lecture and had perfect handwriting on the board this this was the days of chalk boards
none of this said the stuff and no overhead projectors they had sort of thing with the
plastic blackboard we cite them up and down and fill up a room with that and he would start
precisely on time and then since and finish precisely on time noise with a coherent message and
as last few minutes would be a summary and then you could write all the summaries down on your
notes and then you'd you'd have the important elements of the conversation and the talk so
he knew he's a brilliant professor really a nice person a chemist Robert Mulligan won the
Nobel Prize in 1966 while you were there any member of that yes and I knew a new Robert Mulligan
he was in the same building as well I did my research and I would see him frequently he was a
who's an interesting man a brilliant brilliant chemist physicist and and and and particularly
from molecular physics and now he had a whole bunch of students and then post actually had a
large enterprise in those days doing spectroscopy and theoretical theoretical physics and so on
but he's a real quiet man and all of you know he's already all by the time I got to know him and
I didn't have any classes for him but he didn't teach much he was all just 100% research and of course
traveling a lot because he was his world famous but he had a dozens of people working in his
laboratories and then he rires the hall at a University of Caldwell in the space
well it sounds like a tremendously enriching environment or do you tell me about this or the
progression of your of your academic courses there your your research time yeah I work
I had my for shoot up there and then the fall of 64 I was assigned to work for a professor Mark
Ingram who did mass spectrometry and in chemical physics and and various sorts of instrumentations
look at properties of the top-income molecular systems and I worked in his lab as a research assistant
for the first couple years and in Chicago they had you had to take regular take physics courses and
I think of that nature as well as preparing for what they call an entrance exam or the
the candidate exam you usually took that at the start of your in the fall of your second year
that was a very very hard test the qualifier and so the first year graduate students would spend
huge amounts of time studying old tests and problems because it was a three-day test
you know with all problems I mean it was none of this motorable guess that was all problems to solve
and in all areas of physics and so you had to be well prepared and so on for sure I by pass that
the first time through and I was able to get my research started and that was also a test which
a lot of a lot of people didn't make it the first time they'd have to take away six months of year
taking again and then a lot that some people just left it was so daunting that they just left
but that's like a lot of universities have those sort of qualified exams and it's a it's a hurtlet
all people studying for an advanced degree have to overcome but it was it was taxing it occupied
each month your time and you just study it and then to to learn the material to pass those
exams it was rewarding too because there's a focus of your attention and you really didn't learn a
lot I mean if you took the right attitude so it's been a very very beneficial process as far as I
can say so I'm in favor of difficult exams I think that it focuses one's attention and
and and enables you to really really do learn some words and things well then I worked up
if I pass this qualifier exam then you could sort of a PhD program you couldn't formally start
until you pass that qualifier so you'd have to find some professor that would take you on and
then then it had some research project that you wanted to do and I chose to say with the guy
I'd worked as a research assistant because I was interested in the physics and then the programs
that he had and he also is a really nice generous man and he had a you know five or six graduate
students have a couple postdocs and it was it was a good learning environment so I elected to
stay there and worked on some problems in in photorodization we had machines that would generate
vacuum ultraviolet radiation and and use that radiation with monocromers dispersate and use
that use that radiation to study atomic and molecular systems you know ionize them and use the
mass spectrometer or spectrometer depending on to analyze those so reaction products from the
ionization process and it's the density things like cross sections and so forth for
reactions photon atom and molecule reactions and my work that did was to
look at ionization processes in rare earth elements the lathenites so things like
eropium and eterbium eropium and things of that nature we generated ovens made the
old metals room temperature so you have to make a oven and generate a atomic beam all this is
in vacuum of course the generator beam of those and intersect that beam with the with the light beam
and and and and to ionization process you start knocking off electrons and you can melder to
then the ion products is a function of wavelength of the light and determine its ionization potential
so we measured some of the ionization processes of these rare earth elements which hadn't been
done because it was prior to this difficult subsequent people did a lot of spectroscopy
others and they did much got much more accurate results but it's those kind of experiments and
it's sort of a lot of fun you had to build you learn how to build ovens a little high temperature
ovens and and intersect that with all in the vacuum system and intersect that with the light beam
and get the mass spectrometer which is a relatively large instrument to measure the ion products
and we also did some work with organic molecules which were a lot easier you just let them
they vaporize and you can get a lot of molecular beam fairly straightforward from what's per
organic molecule and study their processes and look at their dissociation processes as well
so we did studies of various kinds of molecules that we would look at their ionizations as well as
the dissociation processes how independent were you in in developing these topics was it something
where you you went to your mentor with this idea or was it the kind of get away around?
no you had to end with with professor Engel and you had to develop your own topic and then
convince him that this was something to do and he would support and that's what I did I was
interested in the these rare earths because there was some there was some interest in the scientific
community about some of their ionization properties and also some of the internal energy properties
of some of the organic molecules we studied people were interested in their internal processes
and then measuring their their energies if you will and because the internal energies of these
molecules determine how they combine with others and so on and so there was interest in
and getting things called heats of formation of molecule ions and so forth that we did some
studies on systems that were of interest for other kinds of chemistry because that told you
energy balances in these ion molecule reactions so we were engaged in that kind of research using
these four ionization tools and those days that four ionization studies was hard because you had to
laboratory light sources so these would be discharges pulse discharges with a high electrical
pulse in in a in a capillary tube filled with a rare gas usually or hydrogen subcases and
a lehelium and then you generate the helium would get excited and generate molecular helium
which would then dissociate because helium was an inner gas it doesn't form a molecule except
in excited states and that dissociation process is a mature radiation in the far old devilot
so we'd use that radiation and dispersive with the monocrominern and study these atoms and then
the ion molecules as well but subsequent you know by the time I left graduate school and in the late
60s and certainly now in the 70s on the development of synchrotron radiation and also laser sources
of a total surpland at that to do what we did in those days now you go to synchrotron
most likely it would be fairly straightforward but it was it was hard at in those days because of
the the technology available you're limited to laboratory light sources but now there's the
synchrotron radiation sources throughout the world in fact that one worked as a national institute
of hydrogen technology that was the reason they had a small synchrotron radiation source
at at the institute and we use that for atomic and like for physics studies
same kinds of basic technologies as I used in graduate school and instead of having these
discharge light sources like a neon bulb if you will you have these big big machines that
generated radiation from synchrotron radiation but then as far as graduate school goes you had
to divide your own projects and then you had to publish and then Chicago had a requirement
at that time that your thesis had to be published in the peer reviewed literature so I had to
prepare an article for the journal chemical physics and then once that was accepted that was
and now then you escape the the rigors of half to write a formal thesis that the paper that
you wrote got accepted in a peer reviewed journal was was basically your thesis you just bound that
and that was it and you were not after I wrote these tedious 300 paid thesis or something like
some some places required I thought it was a good idea because if you stop thinking about that's
what you want your researchers to do is be able to publish in the peer reviewed literature so that
that's I thought that was always a clever and insensible criteria and so it's something you had
to achieve but at least as graduate school in your guaranteed at least having one publication
to get you to degree were there any other folks within the department that emerged as being
important to you rememberable besides ingram or oh yeah I had some classes from a famous scientist
Greg Revenso and he was he was a very very good teacher of a no-world gentleman like a swisher
German and he was one of the founders of the quantum electrobynamics back in the 1940s and he was
he was a professor at Chicago at that time and also met I learned a lot from the technical staff
in the physics department of those days they had a wonderful electronic engineer that's I work
with developing building equipment and electronics equipment they had some wonderful people in
a machine shop because we had to make our own equipment we didn't you didn't go to a catalog and buy
a mass spectrometer or monocromber you made it yourself and so I learned machining techniques
and also got to be a fairly good heliarch welder because we dwell that the chambers the vacuum
chambers together and that sort of thing and the guys in the shop would teach you to do all that
so it was I thought it was fascinating I got to do all kinds of things that you know got paid for
as a student that I really enjoyed doing so it was it was a wonderful experience how the years of
Chicago were just really in my mind really really very good and additionally getting a family started
and so on it was a wonderful learning experience did you do any teaching uh case me how I would
teach a course but not for undergrad I teach some courses and people preparing for the basic
exam or the qualifying exam and assist assistant in some of the graduate courses but I never
I was never a recent teaching assistantship and in the sense of teaching the undergraduate courses
and so forth I was I avoided that and I was able to have a research assistantship or
and they were in the lab and never never got so much involved on the teaching side
Tell me about meeting Ruth 1966 that that was an interesting story we uh I was driving out to go to my
sisters wedding and she uh I had I was going to bring an Indian friend of mine guy from India
a menon was his name and he was going to ride with me and we were going to share expenses
well he was a far tougher businessman than I was and he determined since I had that it was
the time the dodge station wagon at the time it was room for others he went around I'd be
noticed to me and solicited other riders to go parts of the trip one guy came all the way to Eugene
I dropped him off on Eugene and but the Ruth uh rode with us uh with a friend to Cheyenne, Wyoming
and we let him off there and I had a menon had some financial reasons I don't know what it was
and uh and so I got to be a courier of people across the country to go on this trip
but the menon figure I think menon figures he saved himself a lot of money and he's turned to the
expressed so that's how I met Ruth and when I got back to Chicago right uh certainly you know
I've seen her turned out she lived in a place where I lived in an international house in Chicago
so we got together and we actually got married and she was a student I mean she was an undergraduate at the time
and you said you started a family yeah and daughter was born there or her son was born there too
and uh in Chicago hospitals so what was that like being a family man and a student at the same time
it worked out pretty well fortunately my wife was real capable and she she worked at some two at
a at a correspondence school they're called the American school and it was in fact it was a block
way from our apartment where we left and so she could go get papers and grade papers and work on
these correspondence courses and uh that turned out a source of income and uh and do that at home
she didn't have to leave it in so the the the the the the the child was was was watched at home
when we lived in student housing that was uh right on campus and fairly close so that's that worked out well
well you were in Chicago during turbulent times uh the 68 democratic convention is
you know well known as being uh uh sort of an iconic moment for that time period in that location
you have any memories of it was awful everybody's bad behavior contributed to a really awfully
vent i mean nothing no one can be proud of those days in my mind i mean the protesters are out of
line but they're in the in the Chicago case the uh police's response were totally out of line and i
think it was uh characterized as a police riot and i think that's about right now i'm a pretty
conservative fellow but i mean the the Chicago cops were were just uh were just not the best
i hope they've changed over the years but you know i got shaken down twice in my in my
usage of Chicago because i had an out of state plate uh license plate uh by by cops you want
to bribe for letting me off and uh it was uh it was not pleasant i mean it did but that's the way it was
and uh so it was uh not all cops obviously but it was a it was a corruption and they uh
they were they were not nice uh not nice to the protesters in those days in fact i was
i never went uptown to the uh to the where all the the convention was but i was just walking
back from the lab one night and uh there's some cop cars patrolling down there by the university
looking for students to to harass and uh i had to they you know well there there's a cop uh
they were followed but i could tell it was a cop by their plane clothesman and they were thinking
about harass me they're dragging by me as i was walking and and really checking me out i could tell
that they were they were not thinking good thoughts they they were down in the south side and i
suspect they wanted to get it on the actions their comments were having downtown and no no the
yeah yeah i i didn't like that that uh the the Chicago cops at that time i had to not a lot of respect
for them because of my personal experiences yeah well which made him work in in family probably not
a lot of free time but i'm wondering if there's anything about Chicago that made a big impact on
you and sort of a social or cultural way there's a lot of cultural activities and uh as a student
you don't have a lot of money but there are a lot of inexpensive things to do well the university
cargo is not far from the lake michica and so you can uh you can just walk down the lake and
have some beaches and and so forth there was a the Chicago museum inside the industry was very
close to the campus and that was a that's a wonderful museum and we'd go there frequently and they
had forest preserves in the outskirts of Chicago that were you know big parks and and so
with an eye and and would spend time there and the picnic and you know the summer so you wouldn't
go out there in the Chicago winter but it's a couple a couple of the guys i worked with in the
machinus and the and uh and uh and in case you go fishing and do something to that nature too
so it's uh it's a it's a it's an interesting environment Chicago it's very different from here
and uh it was a real cultural shot the other big thing that the white 57 Dodge Nadeau about had a
you know it was an organ car right and so the tires were bald and the battery was ancient and the
scissors are getting cold in November car winds start and then the first time i got a little snow
on the street you couldn't go anywhere because the tires I had no tread and of course the
I had a light windbreak kind of jacket and and it got cold and so that November December was a
hectic time i had to get the car up so i would run in the in the winter time and uh and go on the
roads as well as get some clothes that were appropriate for uh you know that 10 degree environment
winds howling so that was a real real real real shocker in my first quarter i was living in
in Chicago i was living in an apartment in about 20 or 30 blocks from from what the university was
so i had to drive back and forth to school and i soon rectified that i got a room at the
international house for the second three quarters that first year and uh we'd say we were
walking back and forth to campus because driving in the and the winters with uh with an older car
is not the best way to get around it was interterranean community and also parking problems in cities
it was a bad move and of course i hadn't uh realized that uh my first apply in Chicago i had been smart
to arrange housing in advance i think it was like for a valet you could just find an apartment you know
oh that's a big city fine well it wasn't the case uh apartments the living arrangements were
were real scarce and it was so it took me a few days actually when i arrived there i'd say in a hotel
or someplace for a few days and i'd like to find an apartment it was a quite far actually far from
the university it was an interesting uh interesting learning experience well yeah and sort of the
continuing topic of cultural shifts he finished up in 1971 in Chicago and went to Alabama
tell me about that well i thought i wanted to be a teaching profession and a friend of mine
former graduate student who graduated went to the University of Alabama and got a pretty good grant
to get his research set up and and so they they recruited me as well to come down and get a research
project started i've been interviewed with them and also with a couple companies and decided
i was going to be interviewed with uh sanded oil as it's called s-sort and those days out in
in New Jersey and they offered me a job as well but it would have been an uh an area in New Jersey
i didn't think much of it besides i wanted to get teaching uh uh go and so i took a job as an
assistant professor at the University of Alabama so we lived in Tuscanos, Alabama for uh
1970 to the 78 years i guess it was and uh and then i went on sabbatical leave at the
bureau standards that was called in in Maryland and then they offered me a job and i decided that
whether it be at the National Bureau standards rather than back teaching and the research
opportunities were far better it was a it was a struggle at you know Alabama's good school
like in the other state school but it's uh in those days it was hard to raise money and uh
we thought it difficult to raise money uh you know from the foundations and so forth and
and and Alabama to get our research started we raised some we were fairly successful
let's turn to my Andrew Jason and I there were insurance and facilities there
but it was very very difficult he spent a lot of time uh just trying to raise money
and so on and uh and also the teaching mode was fairly heavy compared to most universities it was
two courses you had to have six contact hours a quarter and i didn't leave a lot of time for
for your research you just had to be being there all hours of the day and night so it was not
it was not the best research environment of course the thiever Chicago was a guy just
professors taught one course two out of the three quarters one quarter they taught nothing
i mean they didn't have any teaching obligations so i mean there's a big difference between the
research universities in your and your average state university i might just still have a way of
most state universities that professors will have at least two courses and that's very time consuming
and so uh the at the at the bureau standards was on sabbatical leave versus no teaching and
they were fairly well funded compared to what it was at the alabama and it was funded directly by
the government for government programs and so uh eventually i had gotten a position we acted
raised a lot of money you know because uh and bs even said government and organization
we did do work for other government agencies and so we did had programs that in the NASA and no uh
department and defense supported so i raised a lot we raised a lot of money from those agency but for
you know we'll be fine programs rather than you know trying some fundamental research program
like at national science foundation so it was a very different environment i actually sort of like
do a lot better yeah so was the the project the research topic in alabama was that or
it made most of the extension of what you had been doing in chicago yes i built a
i built a smaller version of what we had in chicago and we were going to do do small work on on
rare earths we got started on that and then all small organic molecules and uh i did just
gotten that project started when i went on sabbatical leave and the reason i went on sabbatical leave
was that uh somebody gave it a donation or some money came up somehow they're going to totally
renovate the physics billy everybody's going to have to move out all the labs are going to be
closed down so i says well what other than to sit here for a year i had an offer i had had an
offer to go to to Maryland and the national bureau standards to work with a team there in the same
kind of work uh a photo organization studies and so i i said well let's take a sabbatical leave
it's i want to work for them and uh you know it's just a sabbatical leave at the at the
bureau standards and then that first year i still be paid by uh by alabama and and the national
bureau standard sent them some money to you know to pay for my time it's called intergovernmental
personal act uh pointy and uh so i spent uh the first year there then i was going to go back
we were going to go back to alabama because we liked it that we had a nice house we'd build a nice
house and so forth but they they uh they sat they didn't get done with the renovation things
and go on so they're going to be out a second year so i they had asked me if i would like to stay
a second year at at the bureau standards i said okay so it worked out good then sometimes during
the second year uh early in the second year they offered me a staff position at the bureau standards
which was uh actually doubled my salary and and it was uh we were involved in in a research program
i really liked and really had high national international profile and worked with about a
recent really top people and it was all research and there was no there's no teaching and no
committees and none of this uh my lot of fundraising in those days so uh it was a real opportunity
i thought it so i elected to stay at the bureau standards so we just never went back to alabama
but that was not the intention when we first went to to to get this for Maryland for the bureau
standards and was located what was your impression of the south when you were there and you said
i liked it it was the weather's awful i mean i i never got used to that they the you know the
starts in in May the hot humidity and you know it'll be in the 90s and you would you know by
human i mean 90 percent humidity not people here get off site if it's 40 percent humidity but uh
i mean it would be very very humid and it's hard to get used to i never really did
with everything in your house your carvings air condition you turn that air conditioning on and
layman like i say or sometimes i'm sorry by June and it would just be on until
October i mean it was uh to me it was very uncomfortable now the need is people going up in that
they they they don't seem to bother them but they you know you have to come accustomed to a bite
i never really climatized to that hot you imagine that's the only thing i do like about the
people were nice uh test glutes was a lovely little town it's no say there was a smaller town
bigger than corvallis but it was still it's a college town basic but and of course now it's
it's subsequently a lot bigger they put a car factory Mercedes are one of those companies put a
assembly plant there in in Alabama that's not far away so it's a lot of industrialization
so it's a change in barb just like a lot of college how about the culture of the area
it was uh it was very different i mean uh you know you normally think of it south as being real racist
well they they had their the old vestiges of segregation but it was to me it was less harsh in those
terms than what i used to see in Chicago who was really ugly in my mind in fact the first
department I ran into the guy says i'll give you a real good deal because i want a white guy live
in here oh i think i didn't i had no idea what the customer would do at all i'll take the deal
because i needed a place to say this is could you know i hadn't arranged the housing but they were
they were they were there was definite racism and you could observe it you'd see some of that in
Alabama but not to the extent the race it seemed more harmonious to me than the in the racial
relations in Chicago the events of the blacks and the whites and then in south now that other people
probably have a different perspective i know but i mean i didn't i didn't see the harshness that i
would and they'll work uh things expressed that i saw in Chicago but just one man's take i think i
am sure other people i think i probably very different take on well one thing i'm sure that was
inescapable while you were there was was called football oh god i have one three national championships
during your time bear variant is the coach yeah it was they take football real seriously in the south
i mean the average we're going i mean they just live and die and and then you know place like
Texas too i mean just and Mississippi Louisiana all of that says it is the sport and they then they
really take it take it seriously and and Alabama has this constant feud with Auburn which is sort
of Auburn sort of the quote of working state is it's a land grab school i think and Auburn
because it's in the city of Auburn but there's a fierce rivalry and it's been going off for years
and years and and and and and it and it comes apart of the culture you can people that don't go to
the schools uh you know they're in Auburn and Alabama fan and you know they can be a mill worker
whatever you know i know they'll have their own laws these sort of unknown reasons i see some of
that in Oregon not but nice it's not it's not like it's just it's just pronouns but they do
they do take football seriously and bear Bryant was a really re-burd revered person i mean
people uh you had a lot of club i think for sure well you mentioned sabbatical and you started
up full time at the national bureau standards in 1980 so i guess you can tell me a little bit about
moving to the DC area and settling in and then your first position physicist in the radiation
physics division yeah i was uh i liked i liked it the the the climate of Maryland is a little better
you get you get cold winners in Maryland so you get more diversity it's an Alabama it's hot most
the time even all the way around but uh Maryland it's it's she wouldn't hot in the summertime but
it's a cool sound to fall on the winter you'll get just snow and so on so we uh first year we lived
in an apartment and uh me and my wife and our kids were like that so we bought a house after i
was offered a job and bought a house and lived in the same place i think from 1980 on and uh it's
so i i kind of tried to like it as uh the Washington DC area is a culturally diverse and very
very interesting region it's civil war battlefields you know getty's bergettiedem will run all those
are you know hour so drive away from where we lived in gaitersburg and uh those are all very
interesting and well done by the national park service in terms of historical presentations like
i really enjoyed that uh we uh enjoyed the museums downtown the specific museums are just
me simply the best there is and and and that's uh that's all free and you know from where we were
30 minutes away and uh take the train down now they put a subway system in and we live close to the
terminals of the one subway lines we could do it easily beat the end down if you wanted so
the cultural cultural things are immense and we would uh get season tickets to the
to some orchestra arrangements at the Kennedy Center and that was that was always great crowded
but great i mean it's a traffic is awful downtown Washington but uh uh it was it was a it was a
nice place to live i enjoyed the experience a great deal and uh you know there was uh the
negisites is the weather and it's also very very crowded the the roads the Washington Bellway is
it's truly awful and the road we we were uh not too far from the interstate 270 which runs out
of north of sort of northwest out of Washington and uh it's uh it's a it's a missing busy road
is all a commuter traffic back to port at DC and uh from the Maryland suburbs at the work down town and
this 14 lanes in places i mean seven lanes each way with feet or uh it just it's just awful and you
get on out of each of the bumper to bumper all those lanes and rush hour if he off rush hour it's busy
we would sometimes we would uh basically we bought a boat that we kept over on the chest speak and
even on a Saturday morning getting over to the chest speak which is anapolis uh near anapolis was uh
should have been easy you know hour hour half drive sometimes it lasts a lot longer because
it's just traffic on Saturday morning so it's uh uh very very crowded that's one of the reasons
when uh we retired we we're not going to live in in the in the DC suburbs and uh just uh
we ended up out here instead in order but i think i was in decision we both are really glad we made
mainly the living conditions i mean the coastal activities that you know the
and things and the DC suburbs are really superb but uh the crowdedness and the
and the and the weather are really contrary to my particular likes so some people like it of course
not what i like so we enjoy the weather and the environment here much better
well tell me about the permission of your work doing this uh oh my i was first hired at
oh my i was post-docking i'm not really post-docking but oh my i was working as a guest scientist there
the first year of our civil professor at Alabama i worked in a laboratory with a uh i named Henry
Rosenstock and and Roger Stockbauer well what very well known and in chemical physics for doing
uh in term structures of molecules they're the energetics of molecules so we worked with some techniques
using called threshold photoelectron spectroscopy studying uh a molecular process as small molecules
then at that first year also they were getting started on the synchrotron for so
and this the nymphias has a small electron synchrotron which generates light
ultraviolet light they were getting projects started using cyclotron radiation for photoelectron spectroscopy
so i joined all with uh Roger Stockbauer and a team from argon joe deamer and his team at argon
national laboratory built an electron spectrometer system that uh uh was able to
angler resolve the electrons coming off from a ionization process and atoms with many small
molecules so we built that system at first year i was there and and and then that was another
reason for me to stay a second year and then eventually take a job because that apparatus was
just coming into fruition in terms of this productivity so we were able to do some really really
really interesting things and new kinds of studies using the cyclotron radiation and this
electron spectrometer doing angle resolved photoelectronization studies so some of the first of that
type you know in the world and it was uh it was uh very well received you know on the
in this community so we did that and then build a successively built new instruments in terms of
for photoelectron spectroscopy and angle resolved and participated and also participated in a few
other kinds of experiment experiments and so the laboratory experiments that i first got started
on when we went there uh we put all that all together and track those labs were closed down to make
up all the photoelectronization had to work out that was done with the cyclotron and that's
where i was hired as when they offered me a staff position was to work on the the team of scientists
working on that uh they call it surf cyclotron ultraviolet radiation facility at uh MPS and in 1980
you're 81 they changed the name from MPS to NIST so it's sort it's the same organization but these
congresses in there infinite wisdom decided to change the name reflected a little different mission
i guess was the idea like changing organs take college organs at university that sort of thing
and that nothing fundamentally changed it's just after we do all the letterhead and door signs
but uh it's so i it's i i so i worked in that uh operation for about five years as a as a research
physicist in the uh in the radiation physics division and uh with the parallel to biophysics group
under working with uh under the uh guy named Robert Matten who was the in charge of the
cyclotron and uh very well known optical person the monoclonal design and so forth and so it was
it was a wonderful experience working uh with the the scientists there and the other nice nice
thing about NIST i'll call it that that's his name now is that it's in Washington DC area so you
get a continual tour touring of uh really well known scientists from throughout the world this
is one thing i missed in in in Alabama you know you have to really work out to get the Tuscaloosa but
everybody comes through Washington DC and they would visit NIST in those days and we also collaborated
with a team of scientists on these photon works from from uh from England and uh John West from
Darisbury laboratory in England key coddling from a Reading University in England another people
in our programs and in fact i would then go to uh to England and work on on the on the
cyclotron facility at Darisbury and the United Kingdom and the later stages we transported over
the instrumentation that we'd build it NIST for the flow electron sectorals we transport it
to England this was a big piece of equipment many tons and then uh transported to the Darisbury
laboratory and uh and then near up near Manchester Darisbury is a small town and then the
decided to perform and do some work over there as well with my English colleague so it was a real
nice collaboration between the bureau standard and NIST and the and the English Darisbury laboratory
so i of course i made good friends with me so so happy this day with the
our English colleague got spent some time in in other cyclotron facilities in France and other
places as well to visit it was a very a very rewarding time scientifically and a lot of travel
and and interesting people and that was one of the nice things i really enjoyed about NIST was
that it was the the depth of the the people we've worked with and uh see and some of the best
people from from all over the world we had guests from France China you know in Japan all over
and to come to work in our laboratories and that was a extremely rewarding scientific time
and so i worked on those cyclotroneration experiments until the mid 1980s 85 or 86 something
like that then i was offered a job in another division as a group leader
to uh there was a division that was having some personnel problems and and and they had a lot
of difficulties and i was asked to take over a group that was they needed some attention
and they called the specter radiometry group i guess it was the name of it so i became a group leader
which is the law level management position in in NIST and i think about 1986 something like that
i don't know and uh worked on that division it was called the radiometric physics division and it
was its job was to do all the optical measurements or most of the optical measurements for this country
of standards they did everything from standard light bulbs you know when you buy light bulb the store will
have a aluminum rating on it but we maintain those standards in the standard of the candle as well
optical temperature measurements so we developed that division responsibility to maintain all
those standards as well as to develop the technology to improve the the standards and so the
we worked a lot with industry to uh in collaborative industrial partners to develop better
measurement techniques to help product quality and reliability on the assembly a lot of work with
zero-optic companies like code act 3M that the do have a lot of optical
optical measurement problems for example 3M makes a lot of white paper things like that they should
need reflective standards and how you measure all that and and so on and i spent time with
helping code act developed color of colored measuring processes and optical processes for
properly making a measuring film they had a lot a lot of interest in in in in those days you know
those of the film days the whole technology has changed but then on LEDs and other kinds of sources
light sources that became available we had to develop the technology to properly characterize those
and imagine because they they're a little different little different needs in your incandescent
bulbs and present bulbs and so our division uh to work with industry to develop the right
strategy to making you know reliable and consistent measurements and they came industry standards
how you measure an LEDs properly and so on so that's the the job of that division i've
initially became the division chief of that division uh i remember when that was and uh
lady jewellary nighties and and that's when i retired in 2007 was this chief of the
changes name and then the optical technology division since i've blessed the subsequently
changes name again they've been another reorganization but it's basically the same division
it's now called sensor science division or something like that nature so i was able to then be in charge
of all these measurement techniques and uh and and develop develop uh develop work for other government
agencies and that was very rewarding i enjoyed that we had projects back in the mid 80s
effect was one of my first jobs as a group leader in specteradiometry the defense department was
having problems characterizing very low level infrared sensors that are used for uh satellite
purposes and and uh very very the national security program and uh they had to be sensors that were
calibrated at very very low temperatures uh because they were sensors that would look at the
background of space looking at missile threat that sort of thing and so they they would operate
real temperatures and we calibrated and they make for measurement experiments to make sure they were
seen what they told you they were seen and that we developed techniques to calibrate things that
you know five degrees Kelvin just a little above absolute zero very very low temperatures and
called low background infrared calibration so it's that was a real challenge technically and uh
and that that's facility still in place being used to to characterize uh very low level background
as signals the sensor systems for primarily do the occasionally NASA and other other government
agencies have needs for characterizing very low low background sources things are going to operate
the space primarily uh it can characterize so that was a fun project and uh and develop new
technology and capabilities for the department of defense and they of course would pay for the
department of defense and pay painness for doing this work and so we really saw a lot of projects
for NOAA and NASA for the support that's where the optical did division supporting satellite
technology you see these pictures of the color pictures of the earth you see you see pictures of
the oceans where they they're using cameras from on spacecraft to measure ocean properties all
those cameras and then devices have to be calibrated their spectroreamer system basically
flying around in space looking at the spectral content of light coming back from the earth from
the surface reflected and that tells you about the the properties of the vegetation in the case the
oceans the plankton and then in the in the carbon content of the ocean so we work with a
NASA developed calibration strategies to calibrate the satellites and then involves building calibration
systems for the satellites before they are launched and then trying to build systems so they can
verify their operational and flight and that tells for example the satellites looking at standard
sources in fact there's uh we have one of the big projects was to have a there's a buoy system
out near and not lini and the Hawaiian islands that measures the light coming out of the ocean
up what they call it the upwelling radiance of the ocean so it's reflected light from the sun
going back up and that's what the spacecraft will see you see you'll see the light coming off
the ocean so that's measured out in Hawaii so the spacecraft will have a and it'll fly over
and give them a simultaneously measurement we can tell them what it is at the earth's surface or
the water surface if you will and the satellite then can check its calibration and that's been
an ongoing project in fact I'm still consulting some on that particular project we have other projects
to develop the other projects developing calibration procedures and measurement procedures the whole
range of sensor systems for the for the the no one asks the projects as well as an insurance
department another another agencies that that have a secure program so they have the
University of Physical Center systems we work with them on that as well like CIA or whatever you
know they they have a center programs and we were a government agency that would help work with
them to to develop their central measurement capabilities. Well as I listened to you describe this
said a couple things occurred I mean everyone it sounds like it was a pretty big shift when you
when you switched years to the radiation physics division or to the sorry the great spectral
radiometer on the field spectral radiometry group from doing sort of this more fundamental
research you're doing before to this standard. I suppose a big shift from a fundamental research
to applied research but the underlying theme was it was all light measuring and manipulation
controlling light and sick-crung radiation using light as a source you have to build monocromers
and build detectors of radiological radiation and so on so I'm and then in radiometry the
concentration is not on the use of the light but of measuring the light and characterizing you see
and characterizing the sensors so that someone else can can you know correctly determine what they
with their measuring and in the case the satellites what they want to know is what the
what the the radiation is at one way compared to another and the one will have pretty accurately
so that those ratios those wavelengths will tell you for example the plankton concentration
and so it's all optics of some sort or the electromagnetic radiation but it's a different
emphasis you absolutely right the radiometry division was very applied on the measurement and the
measurement technology and development of sources as well as the characterization of these things
whereas the previously the sick-crung radiation resources the fundamental driver was trying to
understand some basic features of atomic and molecular physics how molecules are and isent
associated so on. It's also the application of science to a very wide variety of projects
some of which apparently involve some national security implications must develop a tremendous
fun area. Yeah it is and very diverse I mean and we had colleagues at our labs in Boulder there was
a whole group of divisions it was concentrated on developing techniques for measuring laser and laser
power and that was you know we collaborated with them too it was fascinating and so it was a real
learning experience and it was also a lot of fun and you know that's the highest level and
these are the best people doing this anywhere. I think our organization had you know in terms of
the national lives it was probably you know the one of the premier national labs and in the world
in terms of the quality of its research and calibration and development so it was a it looks
a really you know a really a lot of fun and it was a very rewarding and intellectually and again
it's the people I mean it's really the best for these were the best people in these fields
in anywhere so it was a very enjoyable time it's a job that I hope everybody can get I mean
a job in a sense that you go to work and you really love it and you you don't try to avoid
working with it that's fun to be there so I really feel fortunate in that regard to have
got myself in a career where what work was really fun was financial rewarding and but it was
it was enjoyable to do and not some people I am doing you talked to there they're always
discrepanied about the working I would never say that I truly enjoyed my career in grad school at
Oregon State I enjoyed being a student I enjoyed graduate school I enjoyed being the national
two-stage technology as well couldn't ask for any more with it yeah well what was what we
were what was your family up to while during the DC era DC years your wife and children yeah my
wife worked that she worked at several occupations she ran daycare at home for a while
but eventually she went back to school to went to hop and john hoppins and got her a master's
degree in counseling and then work in the school systems there and look I'm recanting for many years
as a middle school counselor and so on so she was able to retire from that one only lap
as a school counselor my kids went both went to college in Maryland and they enjoyed that
my fact my son is still out in in that there he lives and he said the
after college he wanted to be a cop he got on he's with the Fairfax County police
it's just across the river from Washington DC and he enjoys that a great deal my daughter is a
nurse and she lives out here in in Oregon City works for Kaiser and in an important area
well I switch gears a little bit and ask you about books and book collecting that's how we first
became acquainted with one another and I'm interested in knowing remember that start how do you
get into collecting collecting books I still have my books from high school I still have a lot of them
and then probably a good portion of my books from from Oregon State to some of them and so I always
just like books and I don't know I like to book some grads of school I always like to read
and then mainly when we moved to Washington and as a Maryland actually I should say in the DC suburb
I got interested in and older books rare books the friend of mine was also interested and so we
sort of got involved in that together back in the in the in the 80s and got sort of collecting
significant volumes back in the late 80s I think and then got interested in the history of
printing was fascinating and how how that affected our culture and my mind that's the ability to
print disseminate information really had a profound effect on our culturally vulnerable religion
but you know education and change change change change so we live and then think and then allowed
everybody if they could learn to read to have access to information and led to things like the
reformation and the real cultural changes and then not to speak of how how it's affected
education if you think about it before the printed book getting the book was very very difficult
getting knowledge was very very definitely good lecture someone had read something but to get a
copy of a scholarly work prior to the engineering of the printing press you had to be wealthy enough to
have to hire somebody to do it by hand or to get to get to get to that so the average person even
you know professional person probably wouldn't have any volumes back prior to the printing press
but the printing press was in my mind it was a great liberating thing for for changing culture
and I just sort of interested in that got interested in the technology of printing and of course
some of the the volumes are just beautiful and the wonderful look at and how they were and how
they preserved the Alexander fascinating too you can buy a book that's 500 years old and
open it up and it probably looks as you know someone look as good as the day they were they were
printed like one of the books that the library has is a 5003 Seneca it's in Latin
but it's a Seneca's works and that paper is as fresh as the day it was made there's no fox in a lot
of books the paper a lot of foxing on it's just a change in the character of the paper but
they last forever it seems like so it's just a fascinating technology but just keeping in mind
the the profound impact it had upon on our civilization and then how we write over now now
this comparable change in the last couple decades of how this electronic environment electronic
we delivered information is going to affect culture it remains to be seen how they've
been integration into the educational process and and in our general cultural
behavior so it'll be an interesting thing I probably won't live long enough to see the outcome
of the orbital it's a profound change how how people can get information and how you deliver
information and so things will slowly evolve as they certainly did in the late 15th century when
the printing press became available and now how education everything changed to
profound me tell me a bit about your methods for collecting that scouting out and purchasing and
I got a topical thing either if I could get a science thing since I'm a scientist I always
would get that if if if I something I could afford and then it primarily was in history I was
always at some interest in history and in history of printing so I have some of the volumes I have
about purely because they were from a given printer and and and and and town like Venice or whatever
from the from maybe the 16th century that would be representative of that kind of printing that
of that era so some of the books were that and then their Walnut scholarly works too like the
Seneca I mentioned earlier and then there's this another nice volume I give you the
Straybogeography which is a early early production of a Straybo who was a Roman Geographer's
commentaries and maps of the ancient world that book is complete with all the diagram maps and
diagrams and so forth and so it's fascinating to Venice and both Greek and Latin and it's fascinating
just to look at that and see the the the the Romans concept of the way the world was I mean the
the master actually fairly accurate with the curvature there's totally displayed and so on and so
forth so it tells you it just shows you just quite graphically how how you know how almost the
ancient really knew about the world and they weren't as as as ignorant as as sometimes portray
so I I get to kick and then the some of the early scientific stuff too there's a
copy of it's in French of Ben Frank was working on electricity and that was published I don't
think was ever published in this country was published in France when he was we spent
any time in France and so a little insight into and to Ben Frank's time as a as a Franco
file I mean serving the country in France so it's in some early Newton it's just it's absolutely
fascinating I think and there's some other interesting early scientific books as well
I think they're interesting but the scholarly things are some good histories you know and
it's a good collection of Johnson the writer poet and his biography for Boswell you have a nice set
of a really nice early early productions and publications and that's here so that's a
important part of the cultural history of the English-speaking people well it's things like that
would track my interest as well as there's quite a few travel books so the early travel books people
back in the 16th 17th century no woman would find us someone to take a trip through the
orient or through the northern Africa the Levant or something and and record it record the customs
of the people and also take along either do it themselves or take along someone to do engravings
and drawings and then make these nice nice printed copies of their travels so when I run
across those if there were a good shape I would try and procure those as well because there was
an interesting insight into the culture and history and in those time frames those those kinds
of things as well I found interesting and sometimes books are just beautiful I mean they're
pretty beautiful and the bindings and good shape and you just say well I gotta have that
well I know that you've taken pride in the fact that you actually read these books too you'll
ask for just them and put them on the shelf yeah exactly in fact I can continue to do so even
I gave working state the majority see this right over here is a deflected in the last couple
years was eventually you'll end up in your library but I got a for example even in the other room
I say on the stand trial often said I got a really nice Bible that one of the first complete English
Bible is printed in the United States in fact it's generally thought to be like 1796 the first
complete Bible and I've some earlier just new Old Testament and and Old Testament's published but
this is a complete Bible called the Collins Bible I believe with the Old Testament New Testament
all the books of the Parker are all bound and one and it's a really good shape so it's something
I came across just recently last year so and there's a big thick book over there is PooTarks lies
and early PooTarks lies in English so that's fun to sit down and read PooTarks was the
Roman bugger for back back and so you want to know about Julius Caesar Alexander the great
these people that have early early early printing of a PooTar of course you'd go down people
a paperback now the same thing but here's a nice early publication of PooTarks we spent three
decades compiling this collection they made a decision at some point to donate it to your
alma mater or be state will tell me about the thought process there well I knew neither one of my
kids is really interested in rare books per se of course they'd be interested in the value that
they're up I mean that goes without saying right I mean they have to be hindered mentally if they
didn't want that you know but if you have a collection like that and people with collections
often have this this issue as you get older so how do I you know what's going to be the ultimate
disposal of it if we my wife might both pass will pass away if these books were still sitting in
the house the children wouldn't know how to they don't particularly want them in their house
but what would they do with them well they would call of some estate agent right and then they
would sell on somebody being here buying a five thousand dollar book for fifty cents right and
and and so that's not too smart the other option well well I could start selling it on myself
that is truly a legal option you could do it and and you might or might not realize very much money
but the the beauty of the donation is you can have them appraised by a good appraiser and
they stayed together as a collection in the case of that's what we were talking about in the state
so others will use them so it was very satisfying when you were and or somebody tells me how the
students are using that was the intent so when we decided that rather than trying to sell them or
something like people give them the organ state the benefit to us is it's a tax deduction so we
get to realize a tax deduction since it's a large sum over over over a period of time and
and and help us out financially so actually probably in the end that's probably more rewarding
financially than trying to sell them and and all that headache plus the main thing is they say
they should get as a collection for others to use and as long as I'm even I get in the car and drive
down to myself you see so I we thought it was we thought about it a while and and we finally
decided that was the part of the best strategy and then Mr. Meek came up and looked them over and
and he said that I'm arranged with your librarian Faye to accept the collection and so it's worked
out excellent and we're really satisfied because the staff of the organ state is just super in
the library and then it's been served the students there because that was a student there and I
don't think there was anything like that there when I was there and if there was I was not cognizant
other so if we can benefit the kids of this state or whoever we think that's that's very satisfying
and the main thing is something we spend a long time at a massing and and have a just good all
and try and sell it it's not that's rewarding it is financially but that wouldn't mean that much to
we're comfortable with retired in another few thousand dollars when we was at this point in our life
as I'm not going to be particularly beneficial so most of us are satisfying to do what we did and
of course I applaud a working state immediately and part because that's where I was graduated from
and I liked it the great deal I have very fond memories of organ state but also one of my friends
probably got me thinking about it was so it was Derek Callahan who was
the alumni or association the foundation for a while and he was he didn't raise the issue about
don't he but he told me about the kind of things he did you know really helping the university
race money and so forth and that sort of sparked my mind well maybe that's something we could do
you know I helped the university out by so we contacted the dairy put us in contact with something
in the foundation and and I'll Ryan I guess Ryan Robinson at the time and working with he and the
the library staff put me in so forth we made the arrangements so we we have found a very satisfying
well the last thing I want to ask you about is you're continuing connection to OSU you're never
the library advisory council OSU is in the midst of a transition expansion right now what is
your sense of where OSU is at right now a very different place from the one that you went to
it's certainly yes and I think what you what's the faith and the rest of you've done with the
library is just phenomenal I mean the library was not at all like that when I was a student here
and trying to transition and take advantage of the modern electronic tools and make it space for
for the for the students to use I'm always impressed when I go down to the places pack I was sure you
back back in the 60s you you'd find a few people pointed over the line but that wasn't a lot so
you've turned it into a central learning experience with space for the kids you know I think
it's terrible important so I think this you got the transitional library to a to a really
part of the learning environment for a large number of students it's sort of exciting it's fun to
be a part of so my wife and I were very interested in helping out anywhere we can and of course we've
had a lot of experience with books and and in education and conveying information so we think
we'd be at some value well thank you very much for this I appreciate quite a lot well thank you
you're some good you want to help out sure